this morning we're waiting to see
whether the pandemic has gotten
even worse because of family gatherings
for thanksgiving the nationwide death
toll from covet 19 reached more than
263 thousand yesterday and for the first
time
u.s hospitals are treating more than 90
000 coronavirus patients
millions of americans celebrated in
large groups yesterday despite warnings
from health officials
adriana diaz is in chicago where busy
hospitals are preparing
to get even busier adriana good morning
good morning well here at northwestern
memorial hospital they've actually
reduced
elective surgeries just to make sure
there's enough room for the increased
number in cova cases they're seeing
and listen to this local health
officials say one in every
17 chicagoans is carrying the virus and
that's why doctors across this city
and the nation are trying to curb the
spread to avoid what could be
a devastating holiday season
i was worried after halloween i'm far
more worried
after thanksgiving hospitals are bracing
for a post-holiday influx of coveted
patients
dr mita shaw works in the er at
chicago's rush university medical center
we will not get a reprieve because then
christmas comes and then new year comes
so if we're just stacking search upon
surge upon surge
i am significantly worried about that
the lobby at rush has been transformed
into a covered triage area
to make room in case there's a surge of
patience in the coming days
[Applause]
and though a projected 50 million
americans still traveled for the holiday
this weekend
outside los angeles this bumper to
bumper traffic wasn't for holiday travel
it was to pick up a thanksgiving meal
from a food bank
so many people just appreciate being
here being able to get out
in northwest indiana volunteers rallied
to keep a local tradition alive
turning a massive thanksgiving feast for
1500
into a drive-through celebration god we
lift up these families who are mourning
the loss of their loved ones because of
covid
for others the holiday was a time to
reflect on a difficult year
members of a church in hard hit south
dakota set up hundreds of empty chairs
outside the state capitol
one for every south dakotan who
succumbed to the virus
and for the spano family in connecticut
dinner was tough without their brother
and son
daniel spano who's in the picture frame
he died from covert earlier this year
thanksgiving was his favorite holiday
we're going to
video chat and you know try to have some
sense of normalcy but
no matter what we do it's just it's not
going to be the same back in chicago
like so many front line workers dr shaw
spent her thanksgiving
in the er you step out of your front
door and you're sad that you're leaving
your family on a holiday
but when you walk into these doors this
is your work family
and right now my work family is hurting
here's why dr shaw and so many others
are concerned
according to the city's public health
commissioner one chicago and is
diagnosed with the virus
every minute erika
adriana thank you